l'europe sociale une europe quand même
encore assez balbutiante 1979 année des
premières élections du parlement
européen et déjà la notion d'europe
sociale et présente une notion qui
évoluera très peu en 40 ans pendant
longtemps dans une logique de marché
commun d'union économique
la définition du mot social et surtout
rattaché au travail
le premier acquis de l'europe sociale
c'est la libre circulation des
travailleurs salariés une fin des années
80 après avoir mis en place la libre
circulation des travailleurs
l'europe se penche sur les conditions de
travail avec plus ou moins de succès
alors que l'espagne et le portugal
viennent d'intégrer la communauté
certains citoyens imagine une
harmonisation des conditions de vie par
exemple on sait qu'il travaille 38 eur
et nous on en est encore à 40 en 1988
les politiques semblent avoir entendu le
message
l'europe sociale c'est devenu l'objectif
principal en même temps que l'objectif
de l'europe monétaire
on va quand même pas faire une icône
remarquer que je trouve ça très bien
qu'ils aient une europe des patrons je
trouve ça très bien on va quand même pas
faire que l'europe des patrons un an
après en 1989 l'adoption d'une charte
sociale et le projet de la communauté
au départ la commission de bruxelles
recommandé une harmonisation de l'âge
minimum pour le travail
une durée hebdomadaire maximum du
travail est aussi un salaire minimum
européen
mais les critiques de margaret thatcher
mais aussi du danemark du portugal ont
peu à peu édulcorée sept chats
conséquence le texte sera vidée de son
contenu et le royaume-uni refusera de
signer l'accord conclu à 11 est un texte
qui ne fait que poser que quelques
grands principes et n'a aucune valeur
aucun aspect contraignant
les années passent et seulement quelques
avancées sont à noter comme
l'instauration finalement d'une durée
maximale de temps de travail
hebdomadaire en 2003 pas suffisant pour
certains citoyens qui sortent maintenant
dans la rue pour demander davantage
d'europe sociale
on a besoin d'un parlement européen
aussi fort que les parlements nationaux
avec un budget pour une europe sociale
une agence européenne pour l'emploi une
robe pour tous pas pour les privilégiés
l'europe sociale et donc encore une
chimère car les politiques sociales
relèvent de la compétence de chaque état
l'europe se contentent elles de règles
communes minimale
[Musique]